[Musique]
alors on n'en peux plus classieux que
l'emballage crépon on a aussi
l'emballage que les Japonais ça c'est un
art traditionnel japonais appelle le
furoshiki donc cette emballage il va
utiliser en fait un textile un tissu
donc moi j'ai pris ce que j'ai trouvé en
fait une belle soie dont le dessin me
plaisait les couleurs la dimension elle
est grande elle est probablement très
grande mais ça après quand vous allez
dans les magasins spécialisés vous
trouverez votre bonheur le principe
reste le même dans tous les cas donc
c'est ça le plus important je place mon
carré bien à plat et je me mets dans une
diagonale
ici j'ai la diagonale
et je vais placer mon cadeau aligné vous
voyez le bord aligné avec la diagonale
et là je coince mon tissu sous le cadeau
et je vais aller chercher l'autre coin
je fais un tour
et je ramène
c'est le même principe que le papier
cadeau en fin de compte et là je fais
mon nœud alors c'est un nœud plat un
nœud plat c'est un nœud de lacet
voilà là mon cadeau voyez l'emballage il
tient et comme ça vous voyez que sous le
sapin on a quelque chose de très joli
dans la tradition japonaise je repars
avec le tissu donc l'emballage n'est pas
le cadeau faites la personne je lui
laisse le cadeau et du coup il n'y a pas
d'emballage et moi ce tissu je vais
pouvoir l'utiliser pour emballer tous
les cadeaux que je veux je le récupère à
chaque fois bien évidemment si vous
voulez l'offrir c'est un très beau
cadeau en même temps